let's get some ready to get some wait
like I said life is always ready to get
so which is a savanna
stand by to get some steady I don't
think people recognize what that
actually means to us that we we knew we
would say this all the time in combat or
train scenarios when you knew that I
mean it is about to go down bullets will
then be flying around as low as you can
be going off and you hear someone very
clearly over the radio just in a real
combo is come up a bit
stand by to get some it's true state
right you know your song but when you
get stayed in that manner I know when
you should be let go
you didn't learn enough song and do it
that's pretty awesome
you